[Music]
what's one of your dearest you know
rules or idea stoic ideas that have
really helped you the fundamental one
that has made a major difference in my
life and it does affect the life of
pretty much anybody who practices
tourism it's something called the
dichotomy of control
the Stoics believe that everything you
do can be partitioned in two components
one part that is really up to you where
you really have control and another part
that you then it's not up to you what
you don't have control because or
complete control because the outcome
depends on external factors and a
fundamental tenet of stoic philosophy is
that you should focus all your energy on
the part that is under your control and
then develop an attitude of equanimity
toward the second component sometimes
you win sometimes you don't but it's not
a reflection of who you are it's a
reflection of the fact that the universe
works in you know strange ways so let me
give you a specific example let's say
that that tomorrow you're up for a job
interview and you know the normal thing
to do would be to to be anxious and say
you know I really want this job and I am
really gonna help then I get it and so
on that's normal the stoic would
approach in this way like well tomorrow
I have a job interview did I do
everything in my power up to this point
to prepare for the interview yes and my
focus for at the beginning of the
interview yes do I know what I'm talking
about yes that's it done then how the
interview goes it's not really up to you
it depends on your competition it
depends on who the interviewer is you
know worried whether he got up in the
morning and
we're now in a strange mood or whatever
and the fact that even if you get the
job you shouldn't according to the
Stoics you shouldn't feel too cocky
because part of it is a result of your
efforts but part of it is you just got
lucky
and similarly however if you fail if you
don't get the interview you shouldn't
beat yourself up because again it's now
under your control you did if you did
what everything you could that's that's
all that's all that it's under your
control so that really does help I think
that essentially it in modern terms is
the the basic notion is to internalize
your goals so I just mentioned the job
interview let's say that you know a
common thought is if you're in a
relationship I hope she loves me know I
hope to be a loving person because
that's under your control whether she
loves you back it's up to her
oh I hope that this friend is gonna you
know really be a good friend well you
can be a good friend that's I'm under
your control whether other people are
going to be different to you or not it's
not and so on and so forth so you can
apply it pretty much everywhere and once
you start practicing that way and thing
looking at things that way you just calm
down
because you say well I'm gonna accept
whatever happens so long as I know that
I've done the best that I could two
final questions so does that mean that
basically I have a continuous dialogue
in your head so one voice is the kind of
anxious irrational voice saying oh my
god but I really want this interview and
then the stoic within you says you've
done everything you could is that what
happened that's pretty much that's right
and in fact that's also a technique that
he's using in County behavioral therapy
to challenge your own thoughts challenge
your own perceptions Epictetus was one
of the major historic philosophers from
the second century and he has this
beautiful way of expressing these
thoughts he said that we should look at
our impressions and impression in stoic
terminology is your initial opinion
about something so for instance that oh
my gosh should I have the interview and
this is stressful this is a stressful
story that's Annie that's an opinion
that that's expressing an opinion
or who
is expressing the opinion the interview
is just a fact of life it's not the
interview doesn't come with opinions you
are expressing their opinion and so you
can challenge yourself and say wait a
minute why am I thinking this way why
why not try to think about things in a
different way and that actually does
work there's pretty good empirical
evidence that you you know it's not a
silver bullet so it's not like you start
doing this tonight and all of a sudden
your life is fine but if you're doing a
regular basis you learn to challenge
your own impressions your own opinion
your own judgments then little by little
you it will become easier and easier and
at some point you stop having those kind
of distressing that's where the
stereotype of the lack of emotion comes
from it's not a question of suppressing
emotions it's it's a question of
controlling and interacting with your
negative thoughts great I was gonna ask
you as a final question about whether
there is a stoic philosopher that you
hold particularly dare and I just
mentioned it but you've just hopped a
button epictetus I think someone else as
well no I think it is good good I mean
the the guy had was an incredible person
he started out his life as a slave and
then he was freed started studying stoic
philosophy became the most famous
philosopher and teacher in in 2nd
century Rome he had an incredible sense
of humor and he had it was blunt movie
students just tall the thing as he saw
so one for instance one of my favorite
quotes from epictetus says so I have to
die well one of these days I'll have to
die apparently this is not the day but
now I'm hungry so I'm gonna go and take
lunch because that's under my control
and then when Ben comes you know we'll
deal with it at that point for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you